9 heures dans le hall de la cour d'appel
les membres de l'association christelle
sont inquiets ils redoutent d'apprendre
la fermeture du dossier sylvie aubert
disparu en novembre 86 est retrouvée
morte cinq mois plus tard la juge
d'instruction chalonnaise en charge de
la faire a signifié son souhait de clore
le dossier et la chambre d'instruction
s'apprête à rendre sa décision
une demi-heure plus tard sur le visage
de martino vers ce n'est plus
l'inquiétude qui transparaît mais le
soulagement on continue quoi on continue
l'enquète et je suis super contente
la chambre d'instruction refuse de clore
le dossier obère et ordonne la poursuite
des investigations et une fois de plus
dans le long combat de l'association
christelle la joie de lune fait la joie
de tous l'association est très fier de
pouvoir continuer dans ces dossiers
puisque on veut la vérité dans ce
dossier
ça nous laisse quand même un grand
espoir au niveau de nos avocats
je pense que ça va relancer un petit peu
l'ensemble des autres dossiers le 6 mars
dernier devant la chambre de
l'instruction m ce band l'avocat des
familles avait expliqué pourquoi il ne
faut pas clore le dossier obère d'abord
l'hypothèse du tueur en série allemand
ulrich muenstermann n'a pas été
approfondi en 2016 un témoignage avait
pourtant établi qu'en 86 il était à
chalon et avait été en contact avec
sylvie aubert ensuite en dépit des
demandes des avocats l'affairé robert
n'a pas été inscrite au fichier salvac
qui permet de rapprocher les affaires
criminelles et de chercher les
concordances sur ces deux points
la chambre a donc donné raison aux
avocats mais tous les obstacles sont
loin d'être levé
j'utilise un peu une habitude dans nos
dossiers qui est de dire finalement n'en
a résolues deux c'est déjà pas mal
et le reste à part fera en pertes et
profits et c'est pas possible pour des
meurtres de jeunes femmes évidemment
c'est totalement inaudible pour les
familles et donc les moyens de son papy
mais juge d'instruction à chalons sont
souvent débordés ne répond pas à nos
demandes nous donne des délais de
réponse absolument quelquefois
ahurissant rappelle que don d'une des
affaires il ya des personnes qui sont
mis en examen depuis 17 ans c'est
peut-être les plus vieux maître second
fait ici référence à la sphère carole
soltysiak délaissé par la justice tout
comme les dossiers de virginie bluzet
marc buisson
nathalie mère et vanessa thielland pour
cette dernière la juge d'instruction a
même demandé la destruction des scellés
l'expérience montre pourtant que de
vieilles affaires peuvent être élucidé
quand on y met les moyens
les meurtres de christelle marie et
christelle blétry ont été commis en 86
et 96 et leurs auteurs sont aujourd'hui
sous les verrous